you've met King Charles as well right I
think we have a photo because I want to
talk about this smirk real quick wait
there we go what's what's what's behind
that that smir okay so he sidled up to
me and looked at my heels and went oh I
didn't realize we were dressing I
shouldn't do an impression of the king
sorry sir he he was like oh you know I
didn't realize we were dressing up and I
said well you did get the memo your
highness but you chose to just wear your
Flats and that's a you issue so yeah
yeah that's not my problem that you
didn't dress up oh my God but you're you
are like tall in general I love when
women that are tall wear heels because
I'm short and I wish I had height but I
hate it because I have tall friends
that'll sometimes not wear heels because
they feel like I don't want to like I'm
all about the heels I love it have you
always been that confident yeah if
you're you know I'm 5' 11 in my stocking
feet and I just think if I'm going to go
in on a heel I'm not going to do an
apologetic kitten yeah no I'm going to
be offensive yeah
I'm go Wonder
[Music]
[Applause]
Woman thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home